Basically, I received a brand, a new brand, or a bodily of curcumin. So I think he's talking about
the curcuclear here. So our curcuclear, I upgraded it. So whatever I find, because there's
new information coming out about supplements, and sometimes there's, you know, a greater
bioavailability with with a different supplement. So then I change it. So anybody that's
a bed with me for any period of time know that. So I changed our curcuclear once ago
to this newer curcumin that is more bioavailable. So that's why I changed the curcuclear. You also
noticed that I changed the burberry. We still have the burber clear, but now we also have the burber clear
pro. And I've changed it all of our cancer patients over to the burber clear pro. It's five times
more bioavailable. It's a new DHB burberry that just came out and literally only a couple of companies
carry it. And we got it and we private label that. So we call that the burber clear pro. We changed
that 80k a few years ago. We change, I mean, there's any time there's something new we want to
at least, you know, inspect that. If this is going to be a better product for people. And it's better
for the money. We're able to provide the new curcuclear at the same price as the whole one,
even though costs us more money. Same thing with the burber clear grow costs us more money, but we're
providing at the same price. So hopefully that helps. It's just been proven to be more bioavailable.